let's talk about some weird going on
weird weird goings on
we have this tweet from tyler carditas
tyler is the ceo of blaze media and he
says definitely something bizarre
happening with the twitter algorithm
impacting follower counts over the past
24 to 48 hours a few examples tucker
carlson is up 62 000 rogan 63 trump jr
87 and ted cruz is up 51 000
however by contrast rachel maddow is
down 18. anderson cooper is down 10. aoc
is down 27. kamala hair is 22. hillary
clinton 17 what's going on
he goes in a mention tulsi gabbard is up
rand paul is up ellen omar is down
here's my response
so tucker gained 62 000 followers in
half a day
he lost 50 followers yesterday this is
not people coming back news broke
yesterday something effed up is
happening now a lot of people responded
saying
my account was inactive or i just
started a new account if you did not log
into your account and then you log in
that's not making a new account like
that's not making a new account you're
not all of a sudden now follow me for
the first time if you were already
following me you just didn't use your
account it existed i had the follower
correct this is
new followers on his account tell me
this when the news broke yesterday
morning that elon musk had was set to
finish this deal with twitter why then
didn't people sign up maybe they said no
no i will only sign up once i hear the
news okay why didn't they sign up at 2
53 p.m when the news broke that elon had
secured the deal
why did they wait until the very next
day
to start signing up
he tucker carlson lost 50 followers
yesterday
he gained 62 000 today
something does not make sense you guys
put it in my mind that there's some
nefarious stuff going on behind the
scenes where they're like oh better undo
that blacklist algorithm that we had
going in secret so that no one finds out
and now it's just this is the
recalibration i mean it's total
speculation i have no idea what's
happening right now well i think it's we
have to speculate and i think the issue
is we're not gonna be able to understand
what's going on until there's someone
inside the elon musk's team gets in
there and asks the questions and
hopefully the records are preserved the
algorithms and what they're doing are
preserved and one can go back and look
at was there shadow banning how many
bots were there how many of
the the bots
how many bots were following you know uh
a congress lady or a senator yeah it's
real tempting as a social media network
to count the bots as people that are
logging in every day there's one point
how many did you say millions of people
log in a day 10 million 113 113 how many
of those are bots twitter's not going to
go out of its way to hunt them down and
eradicate them they're going to let
those numbers stand for so that they get
a better investment interesting i want
to make uh i want to highlight a few
posts though there's a possibility this
is something
not nefarious it's interesting one
person said no people are just
reactivating their accounts because they
want to kneer over the meltdowns good
point it may actually be that many
people deactivated their twitters
and have all reacted reactivated them
right now because
you know they want to be on twitter but
hold on
someone else said
speaking for myself i am back for the
first time since 2018. my phone number
was banned from creating an account
until yesterday so somebody tweeted
saying that they were banned until
yesterday here's another one matt matt
ftm says
i was finally just allowed to tweet and
use the platform two days ago after
being permabanned for four years i
assume i'm not the only one who is
sidelined for having too few followers
to make noise starting over fresh now
though and not going anywhere
several posts i've seen this i i
retweeted someone a lot of people all of
a sudden are saying i was banned and now
i'm a lot back on the platform so yes it
seems like maybe there's a mix but
here's why i don't think it's just
conservatives coming back and
reactivating their accounts it means
simultaneously and by perfect perfect
physics
the left is deactivating as the right
reactivates i have seen evidence of that
uh i went on facebook for all my friends
from l.a who are actors out there and
man they are deleting their twitters
they are all up in arms about it i've
deleted my twitter yesterday i'm done
with twitter twitter so they're actually
deleting it they're not just saying
they're going to what happens if you
delete it from your iphone
well if you delete the app you still
have the account if you delete your
account that's a different story that
probably removes the follower number
yeah i'm wondering how many are actually
removing their account they might not
want to be active but they want to sort
of follow sean king he
deleted his account but then
reinstantiated it deactivated it and
then reactivated it later all the media
reported he deactivated he was off the
platform and then he came back like no i
didn't i didn't do that what he did so
so maybe maybe it really is that simple
that the people on the left are like
harambe saying they're leaving but elon
musk didn't do anything but they doesn't
even own the platform yet they say
they're going to canada but they never
go to canada yeah right they'll be back
i'll be back if we could find out how
many of these followers like rachel
maddow hillary clinton it was the same
person following all those five accounts
and they that one person left so it
looks like five followers were lost well
that's why it's not relevant um
i'm not adding up all the numbers yeah
i'm doing them individually like tucker
gained 62 000.
you think 62 000. so look i don't buy it
you mean to tell me that yesterday
when the news broke that elon did this
50 people were like i'm quitting and
deactivating my account
i wonder if he was shadow banned and
those people have been trying to follow
but it never was reflected in the
numbers here's one possibility people on
the left follow tucker carlson
and so
3 000 leftists quit and 2 950 or
conservatives join so it's a negative 50
number maybe
i don't think the left followers took a
carlson because we know this from
vijayagade leftists don't follow
conservative journalists conservatives
do follow left-wing journalists so it
seems
unlikely i look at this
yesterday conservatives were
deactivating their accounts they don't
buy it you know i think
people are mentioning they were unbanned
for the first time i think elon musk is
going to walk in the doors and there is
going to be something within the system
of twitter that is so obvious and
overtly political bias they got rid of
it they said get rid of it the new guy's
coming in and if he sees that we're in
trouble
and imagine what the press is going to
be preserve the evidence
well they got they have until october to
finish the deal yeah i know and it's
going to be very hard so i'm definitely
very interested to see what it is at the
very least this is exposed what we are
already knew and we already said and
which has been exposed a million times
before but basically if these people are
weak and they're cowardly
you know
twitter was actively censoring
conservatives
and conservatives were still staying
it's not even as if elon has come and
said we're going to instantiate a policy
of censoring left-wing people they've
just said they're going to stop
censoring conservatives and they're like
i can't be here for that
that's the amazing thing people pointed
out that
elon musk is not saying he's going to
wield power against democrats he's
simply saying twitter will stop
putting the boot on conservatives and so
they're all freaking out but liberals
like you said
do not want to read or listen to
alternative points of view even if
they're evidence-based
conservatives
tend to look at a wider cross-section of
information they get blamed all the time
for oh you only get your news from fox
news
that's the farthest thing from the case
because most everyone i know and i think
you know too and the evidence bears it
out even by twitter's own people
conservatives tend to look at other
sources of information that are not
confirmation bias based yeah i mean
there have been studies about this that
we've talked about before on the show
that conservatives are more likely to
understand left-wing positions than
left-wingers are to understand
conservative positions but i think it
even goes deeper than that as
a very wise left-wing
liberal arts major told me when i was in
college when you're used to a position
of privilege equality feels like
oppression well that's what's happening
to them on twitter they're finally
getting a taste of some small iota of
potential equality somewhere down the
line and they are losing their minds
so i'm just trying to we got we got
we've got breaking news
coming in but um
madam
we got we got a ton we got we got too
much going on that was brilliant
oh thank you thank you
yeah so sorry
i was i was checking uh important
saying all a bunch of awesome stuff
thank you oh my gosh this is my best
episode
let's just keep let's stay on this topic
all right continue well no i mean i'm
all i was hoping you would call me out
like that like i'm out of insights
that's it for the night one of the
things one of the things that we're
saying is about um conservativism
looking outside the box kind of taking
in about i think that the scientific
method is actually a very conservative
function um and it's kind of the basis
of modern science there's other types of
science that aren't the scientific
method i don't even know if i come up
with one on top of my head but to say
like it feels like it should be this way
so let's just assume it's going to be
like that that seems like what you would
say is the liberal mind right now
unfortunately
being a little extreme taking risks
unnecessary risks
violates the entire scientific method
where you just try and disprove yourself
and have humility well i it just reminds
me of something secretary rumsfeld said
about the known knowns the known
unknowns and then the unknown unknowns
okay and conservatives tend to be
in my view more exploratory
yeah i think uh
liberals are driven by emotion well and
we've talked about this you use this
phrase a lot the left sees that or
believes that there is no truth but
power and so it doesn't matter what the
actual scientific consensus is on
something it doesn't matter what the
evidence says or what makes sense what
matters is what will get me more power
what will give me and and if something
comes up like in climate science that
challenges their dogma
they attack it they don't want to
understand it they don't look at the
evidence and try to parse it out they
want to attack it deny it and go after
the person and discredit them
yeah exactly and even there whenever
they have a statistic that sounds like
it would support their case they
completely distort it so when they say
things like 97 of climate scientists
agree that humans are responsible in
some way for climate change what they're
leaving out is 97 of climate scientists
did not say we need a green new deal or
that the world is going to end in 10
years or that it's catastrophic but
that's all assumed when they say 97 of
climate scientists agree with our
narrative but it's not the case so
twitter banned ads that go against their
narrative on climate change
that's overtly political the ads
themselves aren't gruesome or offensive
or objectionable they're just
politically objectionable if you have
the wrong opinion this company was
overtly biased
the left just lies and pronouns it's not
and they manipulate people and it works
so when i talk to people like uh stephen
marsh for instance who he was a good
dude came on the show he's like oh i'm
you know i'm just looking at things from
above i'm not on either side
but his world view is influenced by
manipulation and deception coming from
the left and he doesn't even know about
things like joe and hunter biden sharing
a bank account it's like well you're not
in the middle dude you're on the left
you're not doing the research and he's
like i did the research i'm like yeah i
get it you're doing richardson like
polls and studies but you didn't know
that that joe biden hunter biden shared
a bank account now when i say that they
call me right wing for saying it when
it's a fact not an opinion
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there